[Music]
yes
catches marcellus clay is the new
heavyweight champion of the world
have a boys on my face
oh my goodness okay
what cash what
why am i so pretty that was a scene
from one night in miami the
oscar-nominated film that recalls a
real-life gathering of
jim brown malcolm x sam cook and
muhammad ali
back in the day they and other black
cultural women were familiar faces at
venues in miami's overtown section
now one location where they gathered has
become a brand new hot spot
a branch of a harlem restaurant that's
earned national acclaim
there's a new restaurant in miami where
the brand
fits the neighborhood chef tristan epps
helms
too red rooster overtown
so using a local fish from here in south
florida
that's seasonal where he dreams up
dishes like blackened grouper with
broccoli
cauliflower and kale and a sauce with a
twist foamy sauce is a fried chicken and
clam broth
oh my god so we wanted to put like a
surf and turf element without putting a
giant piece of
like chicken on there but still have
that little node to what red rooster is
trying to show and showcase
afro-caribbean afro-latin
cuisine but in the highest way we can
like the fire-roasted wagyu oxtail
a dish that pays homage to the
african-american and caribbean heritage
of this neighborhood
near downtown miami whether it's been
you know latin americans or
people coming from other countries like
oxtail is somewhere
everywhere other than europe it's that
throwaway piece of meat that we wanted
to really really highlight
is that a truffle this is a truffle so a
little bit of summer truffle
obviously there's red wine in this and
then we just like to oh my gosh
all over look at you just enough to
accent it right and just really bring
out the flavor of that meat
the most elegant oxtail you'll ever see
red rooster overtown
is an offshoot of chef marcus
samuelson's famed harlem new york eatery
it's really clear to me you've made this
red rooster
your own yeah you know i was there for
three years and
i kind of took all of the places that
i've been working with chef marcus
and just kind of took it and and really
wanted to cook for the community and
right now this is who i am so what did
you know about this neighborhood before
you guys
broke broke ground here you know the
first initial thing
right was that this neighborhood wasn't
safe
this neighborhood was in fact the ghetto
did that intrigue you at all it kind of
did actually
it kind of did i wasn't scared of no
hood so i was like
i wasn't scared of no hood but what i
saw it was was an opportunity to change
its image
by reclaiming its old one known as
harlem of the south
overtown was a destination a safe haven
for blacks in the 1950s and 60s
people like martin luther king and
jackie robinson and billie holiday like
used to hang out in this building
playing pool because they couldn't hang
out
you know on the beach they couldn't hang
out anywhere else urban renewal came
around
highway cut a highway cuts it through
right
segregation is there and drugs were
introduced
poverty set in and and the neighborhood
went into decline right
so the opportunity to come to this
neighborhood
and basically pick up where this
neighborhood left off
was was exciting to me the reason why i
came here to develop in overtown is
because that neighborhood deserves to
come back
bringing the restaurant here was the
brainchild of developer
derrick fleming a partner and co-owner
of a project he's confident will draw
others to these streets so folks when
they think of miami they think of south
beach
they think of wynwood now how do you put
the harlem of the south
back on the map the history of this
music
this art this aesthetic you can't find
in those neighborhoods
what's the history of this place that
starts to be the defining factor for how
people want to experience
nightlife and socializing in a different
way for chef epps
turning tradition on its head is nothing
new
so obviously grits come first come first
all right bright green
i actually love the look of this take
his version
of the classic shrimp and grits not only
off
color but made with rice instead of corn
so rice without the rice trade without
the crop of rice
america's wealth was really nowhere
during that slave trade we brought rice
so we brought the ability to
cultivate rice and use rice so it's a
huge part
of most cultures in the world but a
really big part of american culture
all right so let's plate this up huh all
right looks so good
local traditions epps hopes will expand
a love
for the community it is so satisfying
to hear someone say you know
i'm 50 60 years old and i've literally
never been on this side of town before
and now here you are sucking on my
peasant dish
you know all the way down to the bone
you know like that is the most
gratifying thing to me
at all i mean of all of it just because
like we put something here we put a
reason for people to come here
and actually see the history of this
neighborhood and so
yeah my my first inclination was i was
excited to come
and show people that there was nothing
that was i mean
it was it's the hood but come
nothing now it's the neighborhood you
know i mean so it's
like so it's it's great
so welcome to his neighborhood jeff
jeff's dying for the oxtail
it looks great what a gorgeous piece oh
the whole restaurant
colors of it the openness just beautiful
yeah they have a tree that they built
the restaurant
around which is like a century old
there's a
carol walker which is on the walls like
they really
took pride and bring like
african-american
culture and every aspect into that
building what did you bring up
oh my god red wine but cornbread with
this special
buttery jam and black girl magic
red bliss the smell of this wine oh my
gosh
yes this is the mcbride sisters i don't
know if you recall i did a story on them
many years ago
and they they feature uh the mcbride
sisters
and their wines they also feature uncle
nearest
breakfast of champions hello did i drink
on television tastes great
i think you've had drinks on television
before